to a disturbing video in Virginia about
the death of a mentally ill man in
police custody the family of Ivo otieno
says surveillance video shows brutal
treatment as he was processed at a state
mental facility yesterday officials in
Virginia arrested three employees of
that hospital seven sheriff's deputies
have already been charged in the case
Jeff pegas has more
my son was
taught raged after watching surveillance
video of the 28 year old's death last
week while he was experiencing what they
described as a mental health crisis my
son was treated like
10 people have now been arrested and
charged with second-degree murder seven
Henrico County deputies and three staff
members of Virginia's Central State
psychiatric hospital that's where
prosecutors Say the video shows all 10
pinning a handcuff otieno to the ground
for 12 minutes before he died you see
him being restrained so brutally
with
me on his neck earlier police had placed
otieno under an emergency custody order
for mental health distress and said that
he'd become physically combative at a
local hospital leading to his transfer
first to a county jail and ultimately to
the psychiatric facility mental illness
should not be your ticket to death
the local police Union Called otieno's
Death tragic but says it is standing
behind the deputies prosecutors cite the
Integrity of the criminal justice
process for not releasing the
surveillance video but otiano's family
wants the public to see it for I'm
looking for answers
why was my son murdered we've reached
out to the attorneys for those charged
in the psychiatric facility for comment
but have not heard back for CBS mornings
I'm Jeff begaze